hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that took place in 1996
in the tournament dos Hermanas and it's
a game between vas leuk and Vladimir
kramnik I've shown a couple of games
from this tournament already but I do
like one a year but now okay I have some
time before the Tata Ste so I thought
let's continue the series and nowadays
kramnik is a retired player vasle vuk
still still an active one still plays as
many tournaments and many games as he
can uh Kik is mostly in the news you
know as s sort of as a self-proclaimed
hero against cheating in chess and while
you know everyone has their own opinion
about that uh it's easy to forget just
how incredible of a chess player he was
when he was active so I'm going to show
you this game uh like I said a brilliant
attacking Masterpiece you will have not
one not two not three but four pause the
video moments in this one and if you
solve more than one I I will I will
applaud you uh so let's dive straight
into it vasel ivanchuk has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to E4
Vladimir replies with C5 he goes for the
Sicilian Defense sorry about that and we
have Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now
D4 so the open Sicilian captures
captures uh Knight to F6 Knight to C3
and here we have Pawn to D6 uh we have
Bishop to G5 going for the Rouser
variation uh E6 and now Queen to D2 so
fairly standard stuff even for today's
standards A6 we have castles and pawn to
H6 kicking away the bishop we have
Bishop to E3 and now Bishop to E7 by
Vladimir Pawn to F4 uh Knight captures
on D4 Bishop captures and B5 preparing
to play Bishop B7 Rook C8 B4 maybe some
Queen to a A5 action and so on and uh
well there are a couple of ways you
could continue here Queen to E3 is still
considered strongest to this day uh you
do have some Bishop to B6 possibilities
but it doesn't really do all that much
you go Bishop B6 just Queen B7 and the
bishop isn't really doing anything there
and uh best here uh would be to go Queen
to G3 uh Queen to G3 is strongest and
then Pawn to E5 so that's the best way
to continue threaten G7 and after black
castles now you play E5 and okay
captures captures let's say queen to B6
and the bishop comes to D3 the game
continues nothing spectacular Happening
Here black will play Bishop B7 bringing
the Rooks to the C file uh and we go on
however here Vel played a most
interesting move he played Pawn to E5
and even though uh in professional chess
this move was last played in 2007 it's
still by far the most played move in
this position if we consider all the
games so let's see why why this is so
poisonous we have Pawn D captures on E5
and now Bishop captures on E5 F captures
on E5 is the standard but here vasel
wanted to sort of take Kik by surprise
and he played Bishop captures on E5 but
Kik replies with Knight to G4 he attacks
the queen and the bishop and now now if
you trade uh well you sort of solve all
of Black's problems let's say Rook D1
goes after the Knight Knight captures
Bishop okay you get the Rook into the
game Bishop B7 also with an attack on
the G2 opponent after G3 Rook C8 and
black has no worries in the world also
he has the bishop pair in an open board
so black is to be preferred here however
we have Queen to F3 he says all right
you do whatever you want I'm attacking
The Rook on A8 but Kik says you can have
the Rook on A8 Knight captures on E five
okay Queen captures on A8 and now Knight
back to D7 and what do you play here if
you're if you're if you're Chucky uh do
you move the queen do you play something
else do you prepare do you do you strike
with F5 do you go King to B1 how do you
play this uh well the most sound uh idea
would be to move the queen you know that
uh once black castles Bishop to B7 will
be played so we might as well play Queen
E4 and after Bishop to B7 uh Queen to D4
you go after the pawn Knight F6 and okay
the game continues nothing um nothing
really happening here but it's still
black who has the bishop pair you've uh
uh okay you've surprised the Kik maybe
you have maybe you haven't but you
didn't really get all that much out of
the position so of course vasel wants
more he plays Pawn to G3 and this looks
uh well this looks mad having the queen
and the Rook on the same diagonal but
okay still you have to Castle first But
Here Comes Knight to B6 attacking the
White Queen Queen to F3 and now Bishop
to B7 securing here the the queen and
the Rook Knight to E4 and now of course
Pawn to F5 so Pawn to F5 the Knight
cannot move but of course there's a
check uh of course Vel s saw this far
ahead King to f8 and now what do you
play here well here Knight to F2 was
played trying to give up The Rook here
uh so the Knight can capture it but
there is an in between move that uh
Vladimir can play here that is so
powerful that even the great vas lean
chuk missed it so feel free to pause the
video and uh solve only the first pause
the video moment uh that I will throw at
you while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it obviously you did not go
for the rook and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to F6 that is the strongest move and I
will explain why because it's very very
important point is that if you capture
the The Rook you're only help helping
White Knight captures on H1 and if you
go Bishop to F6 now to go for okay
Knight A4 and then captures on B2 the
White Knight is in time to go back
Knight F2 and after Knight to A4 you
will play Knight to D3 and everything is
nicely defended that there's no way to
attack the the white king black is still
better uh but of course you you can do
better so after Knight F2 Bishop to F6
was played and now it's unclear well if
the Knight goes to D3 then The Rook is
no longer defended so how can you play
this if you play Rook to G1 you just
just move the Rook then comes Knight A4
and now after Knight to D3 seems like
it's the same idea but it's not the
bishop is still alive Bishop E4 and
white resigns there's no defense here
just a nice Knight captures or Bishop
captures on B2 and that's it imagine
Bishop captures on B2 check if uh let's
say white does something Bishop captures
and G2 check Knight captures and queen
captures and c2's Checkmate so you have
to watch out for that so Bishop to D3
was played you have to cover that um E4
square and you don't have time for
Knight to D3 uh so what do you do now
well you could capture The Rook but Kik
says Nope we continue the attack Knight
to A4 and okay how do you how do you go
from here uh Rook H to E1 saving the
Rook uh even though okay you could try
some other moves but um even with the
engine stop recommendation that is
Bishop captures on F5 sort of to to keep
the the bishop at Bay here e captures
and now Rook HD1 also threatening
Checkmate uh still Queen to C8 just
stops Checkmate and you still have have
all of the the same problems that you
you've had uh before all of this and if
C3 you can just pick up the B2 pawn and
then play Queen captures on C3 it's a
terrible position for white so well you
could could have played better not uh
not much better so Rook H to E1 by even
chuki wants to play Rook captures on E6
and now comes Bishop captures on B2
check King to B1 and now again you're
playing Black here you are you are you
know ass soon to be world champion
Vladimir Kik uh what do you play I'll
give you a couple of
seconds uh the move you were looking for
uh and I'm hoping you were is not
something like Knight to C3 check
because then uh the bishop is just
captured uh and it's not something like
Bishop to B Bishop to F6 threatening all
sorts of nasty ideas here like maybe
Queen to C3 or Knight to C3 check uh
because of Rook captures on E6 and again
mate is being being threatened and if
you even if you play Queen to C8 the
move that we discussed that worked in
the previous line look at this bishop
captures on F5 threatens Rook captures
with check followed by picking up the
queen and even with Knight to C3 check
look at this the white king just s side
steps into the mask of the bishop but
you are helpless here you captured the
the The Rook with check uh White
counters by capturing the bishop with a
check and a discovery on the queen and
after G captures on F6 Bishop captures
Bishop captures you will pick up the
Knight and you have a queen for Rook of
course completely winning so after King
to B1 the move you were looking for is
Bishop to D5 the only move that wins the
game for Kik defending the E6 pawn and
attacking the A2 Pawn but the fun does
not stop there of course his opponent is
the Great vasle Van chuk and he will
make it difficult for you to win this he
plays Bishop captures on B5 what is h
what is the idea here well the idea is
that if the pawn if the bishop is just
captured he will play Rook captures on
D5 and then of course if you capture you
will get checkmated and if you don't
capture the bishop gets eliminated and
you are back into the game however there
is one very very strong in between move
that I'm sure you guys see without even
pausing the video and that is Bishop
captur on A2 this will allow you not to
get checkmated while you capture on B5
so King captures on A2 and now a
captures on B5 and now what do you play
here well King back to B1 uh get getting
away from all the nasty stuff and you
are invited Knight to C3 check as you
will capture the bishop on B2 but again
there is only one good move here one
that is so good or even great that even
kramnik did not find it I mean uh there
are other moves that make um ivanchuk's
life a living hell but there is one that
ends the game on the spot so you know
find the move that even kramnik couldn't
find while I give you a couple of
seconds
uh if you found it uh huge
congratulations this is the move I'm
hoping you guys really found and that is
Queen to E7 uh point is uh like in every
position we have to use the B4 square
and queen to E7 followed by Queen to B4
will be the the the end of the road here
for our good friend vasel point is that
uh uh after King to B1 you go king queen
to E7 and now there is no defense Queen
to B4 is coming and whatever you play
it's just going to be uh is just going
to be insufficient not not right away of
course first you're going to give a
check and then after King captures the
bishop you will play Queen to B4 check
and the white king gets checkmated but
uh Kik did not go for that after King to
B1 he did want to utilize the B4 Square
uh to his Advantage but he did so by
playing Queen to A5 it seems like the
same idea Knight to C3 check followed by
Queen to B4 what could possibly go wrong
well there is a move that U if vasel
found this game would have been complet
completely different and might even have
a different result in the end uh so for
the last time feel free to pause the
video and solve the position uh the only
move that keeps the game going for uh
for Vel while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds I'm sure you I'm sure you found
it uh the move of course you were
looking for is Pawn to C3 that's the
move and that's that's the move that
stops everything now if uh Pawn to C3 is
played the same idea does not apply
Knight captures and C3 now you play King
captures and after Queen to B4 with
check you can escape with King to C2
which would not be possible if the pawn
remained on C2 so here Black's best uh
hope would be something like Knight A4
King A2 Queen B2 going for for checkmate
but now it's white White's turn and
white will have to find Rook to d8 check
King to E7 and now this nasty Rook to E8
with check sacrif ACF iing The Rook but
only temporarily because now comes Rook
captures on E6 King captures and queen
captures on E8 and now it's a question
whether you will be able to get your
king out of checks You'll Play something
like Queen E7 Queen to G6 check King to
F6 Queen T8 with check and white black
is up a pawn but uh you know only if you
can get out of checks and if you can
even if you get out of checks you know
chances are there's not going to be an
easy Victory against a player like
ivanchuk so he did give him a chance
with this queen to A5 move but uh C3 I
mean not not the move you think of every
day here vasel finally cracked he played
Knight to D3 and now it's all over but
again only if you find the correct idea
uh the the bishop is attacked Bishop to
A3 and now what do you play well uh King
to A2 and now of course if Rook captures
an E6 threatening Checkmate which is
kind of the theme of this entire game
for white uh and kic playing this entire
game W without the Rook on h8 okay
Checkmate is being threatened but
there's night KN C3 check King to A1 and
now this beautiful Bishop to C1
Checkmate as the Knight covers the B1
Square so after Bishop to A3 King to A2
was played and now Knight to C3 check
there is no more no more safe squares
for for vassel King King B3 Knight to
Knight to sorry what Knight to D5 now
and the queen is now coming uh there's
no stopping that King back to A2 was
played but now Bishop to B4 with check
King B1 and Bishop to C3 and he was in
this position un move 32 that vas leuk
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh interestingly uh
I've checked uh in in those days rating
lists were not um renewed every month
like they are today is they were either
you know a long long time ago they were
every six months then every three months
then they changed it every month and
pretty soon I'm pretty sure it's it's
going to be like the live ratings but uh
yeah uh on this particular rating list
Kik and kaspar were rated the exact same
2775 you know if you guys are interested
so here mid is coming and if you stop
this with Knight to B2 not a problem
Queen A3 and now it's either Queen
captures some B2 Checkmate or the Knight
moves and then Queen to A1 Checkmate so
uh ivanchuk as usually uh you know he
played a brilliant game uh only he was
countered by an even greater brilliancy
by by kiik in this one and it was
definitely one of kik's stronger
tournaments especially especially in
those days he finished in shared first
place with veling toal there were no tie
breaks in those days if you had shared
first you had Shar first both of you win
the tournament uh and uh just you
know barely edging out vishan tand and
gar Kasparov who finished on five and a
half out of nine and kasparov's only
loss as you can see he's on five out of
five he has three wins one loss and five
draws was Vladimir kramnik and it is the
first link in the description below uh
if you thought this was a brilliancy I I
urge you to check out that one as
well uh it's you know something
something to tell your grandchildren
about uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh probably I will
show a few more nice ones from this
tournament before sorry yeah I just
realized that they are on the robot I I
I would hate to trick you guys know this
was a classical game so this I just
lefted this from the previous video I'm
sure some of you already commented on
that but you know what are you going to
do
um yeah like I said uh hope you guys
enjoyed it uh it's one of those
masterpieces that are rare and that uh
probably will not happen today uh
because uh today they all have the same
lines they they all have the same
engines back in those days okay this is
1996 it's hard to say you know the the
earliest engines were employed in maybe
year 2000 and even then the players
didn't really trust them then maybe in
2002 they started taking them a bit
seriously once some new ideas uh have
been in introduced but uh Vladimir Kik
is I believe one of the first who really
started taking engin seriously I I think
I saw a interview with udith pogar where
she mentioned that she just you know
never trusted the engine she said okay
maybe it's a nice move but I just don't
trust the engine and um you know I'm
pretty sure Kik was one of the first to
really take them seriously and to you
know try to take advantage of them I
just don't think it was uh possible in
1996 like uh those were the days you
know even even the absolute strongest
super computers like like deep blue in
1997 that faced G Kasparov uh you just
couldn't uh like have that at home uh
you
know for most people uh but okay I hope
you enjoyed it we'll probably show a few
more games uh I would like to thank
welshan Wan Sasha vidler Mark Henley
Brennan and Michael Maes for M mes for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out kaspar versus crck from the same
tournament first link in the description
below see you soon